You know,
[Silence]
the
new
ending
the
much
tribe.
Islam
grudgingly
enter
the or
they are distributed according to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's command 1/5th
is to Allah and his messenger meaning to
betterment of the Muslim to bal
The other four fifths are distributed to
the various soldiers based on their
position and rank and based on their
contribution to the military.
Now aside from
we have another type of spoil of
spoils of war that is to the discretion
of the prophet sallall.aii.
This is beyond
al this is beyond just what is captured
of the enemy whether it be prisoners of
war whether it be whatever it is that
they have taken spoils of war it's a
military so they have wealth and they
have armor and they have different
you know horses and things that
that they distribute ute. But there is
also other types of wealth that is given
by a people once they are defeated. Not
just the military immediately but the
homeland that this military comes from.
Now much of this is to the discretion of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. He had
already divided up the
He had already divided up the spoils of
war. Now there is an additional portion
that he has the liberty to distribute as
he sees fit. Sallai wasam.
This is what he is distributing here.
this addition.
This is not a right that a soldier
holds that he is to receive this much as
a ganima is. This is an addition to
that. So he could give all of it to one
person if he saw fit. He could give it
all to everyone equally if he saw fit.
It is to his discretion. Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. Everyone's already
taken their rights as Allah has
stipulated in surah and elsewhere. And
so this addition, this is what the
prophet is distributing here in this
narration.
And so Abdullahbn Masoud says after the
battle of Banain was concluded, the
messenger of Allah sall.ai alaihi
wasallam gave certain key people, key
individuals and key figures
that extra that we just discussed
and gave some more than others. He gave
some more than others.
And so Iban Masoud names to us the kinds
of people or the names of some of these
individuals. So he mentions
Habis and he mentions
these two individuals
were considered to be very u
somewhat rebellious. Their Islam was
very unstable
but they were high ranking chieftains in
their own right amongst their people.
They were tribe leaders but as Muslimian
they were very unstable in their Islam
especially at this time in the battle of
Kunain and even
is some of them even apo apostated from
Islam after the prophet's death saiam
though Some of them returned to Islam,
passed away upon Islam. However, that
rebellious streak and that instability
never really left them. And so the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam using his
judgment and using his resources gave to
these kinds of people much more than he
gave to the more stable
companions.
Why? Because Islam has not yet entered
these men's heart. And behind these men
stands hundreds if not thousands of
people
whom their Islam depends on what
their tribe leaders do. If their tribe
leaders become Muslim, they all will
become Muslim. The entire tribe. If
their tribe leader wages war against the
Muslim, they will all die fighting
alongside or behind their tribe leader.
This is how the culture was at the time.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam gave these unstable tribe
leaders Oyb and Habis and others
much more than he gave to the other
Muslim who have earned much more than
and
but he's not worried about their Islam
their Islam is stable in another
narration Abdullahbn
he asked the prophet Sam
about this. He said, "Oh messenger of
Allah, you gave to this person but this
person over here is a much better
Muslim.
He is a much better Muslim and I am
almost certain that this person is
very strong in his iman etc etc almost
as to reward him for his iman. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said to
Abdullahb,
"Don't you understand?
When I give a lot to one person, it's
because I'm afraid that this person is
so unstable that the only thing that
will keep them in Islam for the moment
is this. Is this wealth that I'm giving
them out of mercy for them that Allah
does not dump them on their faces. As
for these other good Muslims that you're
speaking about, I am not giving them as
much because
I'm not worried about their iman. Their
im will keep them
stable in Islam. Whether they're given
of the wealth of this dunya or not,
they're here because they believe,
because they want to be here. these
other people he's giving them because he
is afraid that they're unstable. So this
is the context here. Now
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
didn't oppress anybody. He didn't take
the rights of some and give it to
someone else. No, he gave everyone their
right and then these few people he
gave them extra from his portion.
Sallallah.aii wasallam that is to his
discretion.
And so when he gave
people like
and
these different tribe leaders,
some of the people that had accepted
Islam and accepted Islam in Medina, but
they were people who had hypocrisy in
their heart. They said,
he commented and said, one man commented
and said,
"This distribution
has is not just and this distribution
has not been for the sake of Allah.
Accusing
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam of
injustice and accusing the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam of
insincerity
which in themselves could be interpreted
as apostasy on their own and in
their own
on their own. So inshallah we will
continue this tomorrow. the remainder
of the
subhanahua.
[Arabic recitation]